mike pompeo fox news contributor former
secretary of state good morning to you
mr secretary
good morning steve good to be with you
all good to have you so the
administration can't figure out why the
migrants are coming i think it's pretty
easy they're coming because the
administration is making it easy for
them to do that
steve i think that's right this isn't
about root crosses we know why people
want to come to the united states it's a
great place it's the greatest nation the
history of civilization the reason that
they're able to come and the reason so
many are actually choosing to come is
because this administration has
abandoned any pretense of protecting
american sovereignty they're focused on
sovereignty for the ukrainian people we
should do that here at home and they
they gave up all the good work that we
had done for four years we had laid down
a set of policies that had slowed down
people coming across the border and
steve importantly slowed down fentanyl
and drugs that are impacting our
communities all across america from
coming across the border as well and we
should never forget there's a lot of
ungoverned space in mexico where terror
threats are very real if we don't know
what's coming in and out of our country
it's not that difficult to do the
administration just needs to be serious
about it and apparently they've just
given up the progressive elements inside
of their party one open borders and
that's what we've got today uh it's
incredible because uh the chinese are
giving fentanyl to the mexican cartels
who are poisoning us so together they're
helping destroy america at a dizzying
rate from middle class uh on down but i
think it's uh i want to get you to weigh
in on the fact that russians and
ukrainians uh people from europe are now
coming to our border in record numbers
if that happens when you're as secretary
of state
and and when you have the vice president
go down to honduras which he says the
root cause of the problem with private
money that she raised to help on doors
to build their economy how do you feel
about the way they're attacking some of
the challenges of the border from all
these different countries
brian it's one thing it's fine if we
want to provide humanitarian assistance
to some country that is separate from
the importance and the the project which
is protecting american sovereignty and
protecting our border not just our
southern border but ports too where
folks come in and just overstay visas we
had a comprehensive program aimed aimed
at this it was pretty straightforward if
you come here and seek asylum fair
enough you're not going to stay here
while you do
and we told these folks you're going to
remain in mexico and what happened when
we did that was pretty clear it shut off
the spigot the magnet was turned off and
we had
largely supported ice and cbp in a way
that enabled them to protect american
sovereignty these these drugs these
weapons all of this stuff coming across
the border is in everyone's best
interest who hates america who wants
american decline we ought to protect our
country in a way that we know how to do
and is easily within our reach i want to
ask you about afghanistan because the
united nations says that there are
credible allegations that 100 former
former afghanistan government officials
troops and those who worked with
coalition forces have been killed by the
taliban since the u.s troop withdrawal
devastating news not surprising though
but these people were killed because
they worked with the united states what
do we do about this
carla when you leave friends and allies
and americans behind this is the kind of
thing that happens i've seen that u.n
reporting but i also have first-hand
knowledge that this has taken place
we still have folks who want to get out
of that country folks who supported our
soldiers our sailors our diplomats our
intelligence services while we were
there they helped us take down terror
plots against the united states for
years and years and years and when this
administration ripped up the trump
administration's plan and abandon those
people this is exactly what one would
expect would happen to your point carly
this is not surprising that the bad guys
are acting in this way to take vengeance
on those who fought against them for
years when they have virtually
unfettered control inside of their
country mr secretary let's talk about
another hot spot and that is what the
heck is going on with ukraine and russia
as well there have been diplomatic
negotiations apparently doesn't seem
like much is going on yesterday uh ned
price who is a state department
spokesman uh clashed at locked horns
with the associated press reporter matt
lee about you know
what's happening what are you doing
watch this
did the security council actually do
anything
matt uh this was not about uh
a resolution it was not about a vote uh
this was about an exposition of the
facts
expositions after expositions after
expositions of this going back
you yourself get up here every single
day and talk about or whenever you get
up here i'm going to say
i mean just when you're briefing you get
up here and you talk about the g7 you
talk about the eu you talk about nato
you talk about
you know and
and any number of international for us
that where this stuff has actually come
out and been agreed on matt we are not
for engaging in robust diplomacy
uh mr secretary uh he the reporter for
the associated press has been there a
very long time he knows what he's
talking about to a lot of people it
looks like the administration is doing
too much talking and not enough doing
the most important word in that
conversation was talk it's what the
reporter kept referring to talk talk
talk in the end vladimir putin
understands deeds his oligarchs the
people who are around him need to
understand that they'll be cut off from
the things that they love traveling to
london and paris and to the united
states all the things that these folks
value they need to know are being held
at risk but what they have seen carla we
were talking about afghanistan we opened
talking about our border they've seen
weakness a leader who's not prepared to
defend the things that matter most to
the american people all across our
country i don't know if we've been
watching but prices of wheat red wet red
winter wheat that comes out of ukraine
and russia are beginning to become
destabilized 30 of that comes through
the black sea right south of ukraine
these are the kind of things american
presidents have always protected this
one doesn't seem prepared to and when
it's a talk talk talk the russians will
understand act act act so how do you
feel and some people don't have a
problem with this but macron seems to be
on his own
with the so-called normandy group
we have our vice our secretary of state
talking to
lavrov today we have vladimir putin
talking with the president of hungary
does it bother you and it might not that
the u.s and nato
and the eu seem to be on on different
uh conference settings
needs to be together it needs to be this
thing president biden promised he'd
deliver he says we're back america's
back our european friends will love us
again it's not about being loved it's
about being respected we need the
germans the french to get on board with
the american effort to push back against
vladimir putin when there's a gap when
there's a space brian you know this
story well when there's a place to run
vladimir putin will find that lowest
point of resistance and he'll build a
nordstrom two pipeline he'll threaten
the ukrainians he'll do just exactly
kind of things that impact people all
across the united states of america yeah
well you know right now it's a big
guessing game and some foreign policy
experts say that vladimir putin isn't
going to invade ukraine uh during the
olympics because he doesn't want to
outshine um his best friend in china um
and then others say that it's eminent so
when do you think
this is going to happen if it does
and what does that mean for the american
people
so predicting timelines is very
difficult
xi xingping and putin certainly have a
common alliance but they're not
particularly close in that sense uh that
we shouldn't take our off the ball
either we're going to hold the genocide
olympics where our athletes are going to
be forced to be muzzled for weeks while
they're on the ground in beijing
presenting real risk to them
for the american people it matters
because if the united states is weak in
the world the the dollar is the reserve
currency is risk could not raise
interest rates we could have energy
prices skyrocket in the united states as
well we need stability in these places
and the united states has the capacity
to achieve that that we'll just do the
right things and uh deter aggression in
the way that we did for four years sure
of course uh before you were secretary
of state before you ran the cia you were
a congressman from the great state of
kansas that's why you know about the
price of winter wheat
when you look at at the city you know
we've been talking about how the
administration has been handling various
foreign affairs what about domestically
you know our lead story this hour uh and
last hour is crime and it does not seem
like this administration is putting the
same kind of emphasis on crime that a
lot of people would like to see them do
steve much like in foreign policy work
they put climate ahead of everything
else
here they've put the idea that can't we
all just get along and refusing to make
sure that bad guys are put in jail in
the way that we always know we have to
do not only to deter the particular
individual take them off the streets
which is just common sense but to make
clear that it's unacceptable to raid a
cvs or a walgreens
we saw this back from the summer of 2020
when the progressive movement allowed
these rights to take place in cities all
across america and they said well this
is just people venting this is
unacceptable in the united states we
have a responsibility to protect every
american citizen and local law
enforcement state law enforcement
officials need to be given the power to
do so and district attorneys need to
prosecute to them to the full extent of
the law you remember um when you were
secretary of state obviously i had
director first
when you brought up things like i think
that the virus kova 19 came from a lab
uh you were marginalized like tom cotton
or taken down from youtube uh now we
find out that not only was there
something substantial to that even the
people in the know thought of that and
they were told basically to they were
told to muzzle up for the good of
science and this is something that's
going to be expanded investigation
here's one quote dr nikolai pedrovsky of
the flinders university medicine
professor he said this it shot from
every direction from people who we now
know are actually thinking exactly the
same thing but have chosen to say the
opposite which is extraordinary it's
taken two years for that to finally come
out and be exposed and what they're
talking about is these scientists who
said i think this came from a lab leak
and then quickly a conference call was
put together uh by fauci and his boss
francis collins to say guys let's get on
the same page this happened naturally in
fact fauci said it last week on a
podcast this came out naturally bring us
inside the mind of science and
international relations
i can tell you this brian in spring of
2020 it was clear to me personally and i
think to a large number of people who
had access to the data that this almost
certainly came from the wuhan institute
of virology i said it publicly in the
spring i think it was
march or april of 2020. you're right we
were pilloried and now you're seeing
this on be unpacked i don't know the
details of what was going on inside the
medical community in the us government
medical community but it is now very
clear that dr fauci knew that there was
u.s money going to the echo health
alliance almost certainly to be
performing gain of function research
inside of china probably to evade u.s
restrictions there's a lot more to learn
it still matters brian it matters to the
american people don't forget that lab is
still open and operating inside of china
today right
mick mulvaney said he was uh i think he
was chief of staff at the time he said
president didn't know about this he
didn't know about the exchange between
the scientists didn't know about any of
that how unbelievable is that
it is unbelievable that you had senior
medical officials u.s government
officials that weren't sharing with the
senior leaders of america what they knew
about was likely the cause of what we've
now seen
kill millions of people across the world
hundreds of thousands here in the united
states and do untold
damage to american society yeah let
alone four and five-year-olds we're
still dealing with who still don't know
their abcs because of it uh it's killed
it will have killed close to a million
people in the united states it is
terrible uh thank you very much mr
secretary we know you got to go today
thank you thank you steve thank you
thanks brian thank you so much thanks
for starting with fox and friends hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now